they wear the pacquiao that's what I
want to talk about um you know
overwhelmingly people were texting me
come Sunday morning and say this is kind
of like a disappointing fight because I
didn't stay up to watch it but this is a
disappointing fight yeah and the weeks
leading up to this fight we heard every
superlative most lucrative biggest fight
of the century and while the money
rolled in it's going to be over 100
million dollars for each fighter this
isn't the fight that's gonna save boxing
by any means it was kind of boring it's
how Floyd Mayweather fights all his
fights for people the not the casual
boxing fan or the fan that tuned in that
isn't a boxing fan it wasn't that it's
not a brawling fight that you saw from
Mike Tyson or even lighter guys like
Hagler and sugar in it okay so they're
each gonna go away with you know 100
million dollars or so right but it was
actually or more um
but did it break television records it's
too early to tell but by all accounts
yes everyone I talked before the fight
said they're not gonna know for later
this week but it's it's pretty much
guaranteed because of all the hype right
because these guys have been talking
about fighting for six years I'm sure
you know a lot of your friends that
aren't boxing fans tuned in that's right
became a postural touchstone and some
well I thought it was love seeing the
photos of the Filipinos in the
Philippines hazy like gathering all over
the country watching Pacquiao okay the
Kentucky Derby American Pharoah this was
kind of an usual I said usual to see a
favorite actually win yeah and it he was
supposed to win by a lot more than he
did and David Papadopoulos who covers
horse-racing for us mentioned he was
whipped 32 times during the race which
is rare for that horse wasn't whipped at
all and it's two wins this year so
American Pharoah worked harder than a
lot of people thought the horse would to
win this race win this race so there
guess the question is did that bode well
exactly the question I don't know it's a
no fishing expert but from what I've
heard it sounds like there's concern
that if the horse worked this hard for
this race that's a no California chrome
pot no is it we never know thanks racing
world has been waiting for this for a
very long time as you know a Triple
Crown hasn't happened in a long time
since 1970 exactly before you were born
everything they'll be they'll be rooting
for that's for sure
okay and one of baseball's biggest
rivalries right Yankees versus Red Sox
so a-rod hit this Homer what was it hit
the 660 okay so rip made this record the
he's not gonna get paid for it it's so
funny the Yankees do so well at
marketing literally everything about
their franchise you know when Derek
Jeter retired you could buy the dirt
that he stood on for his final at-bat
and because of Iran's history and
obviously this up he's dressed a lot of
content in there it sounds like that
obviously they didn't market it and
they're not going to pay him that six
million dollar bonus it's certainly a
weird situation and I'm sure the Major
League Baseball Players Association is
going to have something to say about
Arad not getting that money well he
still got some making up to do sounds
like Evan thank you so much happy Nobby
Williams our Bloomberg Sports report